>> Bret: THE DELAVAN HAS BEEN
BUSY THE LAST FEW HOURS WITH
SUICIDE BOMBING OUTSIDE OF THE
AFGHAN INTERIOR MINISTRY
INTERIOR MINISTRY AND A TAX TWO
OTHER SECURITY INSTALLATIONS
WHICH LEFT AT LEAST NINE VICTIMS
DEAD.
TONIGHT NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN LOOKS AT THE
PRESIDENT'S REVAMPED STRATEGY IN
THAT COUNTRY AND WHETHER IT'S
WORKING.
>> Reporter: U.S. MARINES
KILLED MORE THAN 50 TALIBAN
LEADERS IN AN ARTILLERY STRIKE
AND HOW MONT PROVINCE.
THE TOP COMMANDER IN AFGHANISTAN
CAUTIOUSLY TOUTED THIS A
SUCCESS.
>> THE TELE- BAND DRAWS 60% OF
THE REVENUE FROM NARCOTICS, AND
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
>> A TELE- BAND SPOKESMAN SAID
NONE OF ITS LEADERS WERE KILLED,
CALLING THIS U.S. PROPAGANDA.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT JOHN
NICHOLSON HAS SPOKEN TO THE
PENTAGON PRESS INTO MONTHS.
>> BY KILLING LEADERS, WE WILL
ACHIEVE A DISRUPTIVE EFFECT.
>> THE U.S. MILITARY LAUNCHED
THE SECOND LARGEST NUMBER OF
AIR STRIKES AND SIX AND A HALF
YEARS.
RECENTLY, U.S. DRONES KILLED
DOZENS OF TALIBAN FIGHTERS
ATTEMPTING TO TAKE OVER WESTERN
FARAH PROVINCE, WHICH BORDERS
IRAN.
IN JANUARY, 810     810 WORK HAR
IN JANUARY, 810     810 WORK HAD
IN JANUARY, 810     810 WORK HAJ
IN JANUARY, 810     810 WORK HAT
IN JANUARY, 810     810 WORK HAS
ARRIVED TO PROVIDE MORE COVER
FOR AFGHAN TROOPS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS,
THOUSANDS OF DRUG LABS HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED.
BUT TALIBAN LED ATTACKS REMAIN A
REAL THREAT.
TODAY AFGHAN SECURITY THWARTED
AND ATTEMPTED SUICIDE BOMBING AT
THE INTERIOR MINISTRY IN KABUL.
>> THE AFGHAN GUARDS IMMEDIATELY
RECOGNIZE THE IS AS OLD
UNIFORMS, THEY CALLED ON THE
THEM TO EXIT THE VEHICLE SO THEY
COULD BE CHECKED OUT AND THEN
THE FIGHTING STARTED.
>> LIEUTENANT GENERAL SCOTT
MILLER WHO CURRENTLY HEADS AT
U.S. JOINT SPECIAL OPERATIONS
COMMAND WILL TAKE OVER.
HE WILL BE THE NINTH U.S.